hey guys what's up I'm Brett from GQ and
I'm here with my main man Rob Greg and
we're talking all things custom suiting
tell me a little bit about what a suit
does for your confidence as soon as
everything and it really comes down to
the fit so for me as a guy it's really
tough to be confident if you're
uncomfortable in your clothes so I was
out for a custom tailored suit when I
can and I love this one this one fits
you to a tee this is Joseph Abboud at
Men's Wearhouse it's made in America
yeah I love this it's a really nice
light breathable fabric you obviously
got the pick stitch details it's nice
touch
get the hacky pocket ticket pocket it's
a full three-piece definitely my go-to
it's really a cool suit all around you
spend a lot of time on the East Coast
also on the west coast what's the big
difference between the two on the East
Coast it's darker bolder colors West
Coast I like that a little bit more fun
with its and lighter fabrics playful
materials and fish so it keeps that nice
crisp GQ look so guys you heard it from
rob you heard it from me
whether you live on the east coast or
the west coast custom suiting is the way
to go look sharp and it's smart